m
dans le cadre de la journée nationale du
harcèlement scolaire le conseil
départemental a organisé une
manifestation ce jeudi 5 novembre dans
l'hémicycle du palais de la source
une rencontre entre collégiens et
professionnels afin de renforcer
l'information la prévention et la lutte
contre les violences en milieu scolaire
alors le rendez-vous de ce matin est
dédié à la question du harcèlement
scolaire
le département met en oeuvre une série
d'actions en direction des collégiens et
l'actualité de ces dernières années avec
un fait divers qui s'est produit dans un
de nos établissements en 2013 a été le
point de départ d'une série d'actions
visant à donner la parole aux élèves est
aujourd'hui eh bien on donne les moyens
de s'exprimer sur la question du
harcèlement scolaire
on a évité dans l'hémicycle aujourd'hui
huit collèges du département
représentatifs du territoire
et comme vous avez pu voir ce matin les
marmailles et bien on leur a donné la
parole et ils apprennent des jeunes qui
ont choisi de s'exprimer afin de faire
cesser la violence subie mais aussi agir
pour que d'autres élèves ne soient pas
victimes à leur tour victimes de cyber
harcèlement c'est à dire le harcèlement
via un parent est géant et un jeune de
14 ans je suis créé un conte h
si c'était vous posez des questions
anonyme a écrit hong lei et c'était de
super u est le plus souvent j'ai été
harcelée par une inscription tricot ne
sais pas je donnais des poser des
questions à ces arts de calais est ce
que c'est bien fait l'amour ou encore la
marque mais aussi traiter de grosse déjà
sur quoi il se trouve que c'est très
important de parler parce que si on
garde ça pour soi un moment ça va
exploser
il ya et c'est comme une bulle 2 qui est
la sortir du vhc on peut pas garder ça
pour soi il faut pas oublier qu'on est
la liberté d'expression c'est un droit
de parler reconnu aujourd'hui comme une
priorité nationale le harcèlement
scolaire se définit comme une violence
répétés qui peut être verbale physique
ou psychologique
pour emmanuel péters assistante sociale
il devient essentiel de briser la loi du
silence est ce qui caractérise le
harcèlement sèchement le silence
si si c'était facile on pourrait on en
parlerait même pas comme d'une
problématique suffirait d'être victime
de quelque chose et on le dénonce
non il ya tout un travail à faire pour
aider cette personne victimes à sortir
du silence à sortir de son isolement
également il faut savoir plus
harcèlement c'est pas seulement un acte
répéter malveillance est aussi un
isolement dans lequel on enferme sa
victime
donc il ya toutes ces étapes à franchir
parler c'est déjà agir
c'est pas c'est pas bateau de dire ça
parce que je vois ça au quotidien
quand on fait un parallèle avec d'autres
problématiques comme la maltraitance ou
les violences intrafamiliales quand on
parle on a déjà un pied dans une action
on n'est plus complètement dans une
situation de soumission la lutte contre
le harcèlement scolaire est une priorité
en effet ce phénomène a des conséquences
graves parfois dramatiques souvent le
harceleur minimise la dangerosité de ces
actes qui sont pourtant cru elle est
punie par la loi falloux bas il faut
comprendre
aux jeunes et aux parents que le
harcèlement c'est une infraction pénale
punissables de peines de prison et
d'aller d'amande donc un mineur qui est
qui et qui est dénoncé comme harceleur
et qui a prouvé qu'il était un harceleur
va il risque d'être présenté devant un
juge des enfants
c'est le juge qui décidera de la peine
appropriée en plus des mondiaux des
sanctions au niveau scolaire aux écoles
une journée d'échangé de partage qui a
pour but de faire appel à la
mobilisation de tous pour un climat
scolaire apaisé et serein
le harcèlement scolaire est un fléau
suivi depuis deux ans par le conseil
départemental à la réunion dont la lutte
est inscrite dans ses priorités d'action
annuel